Okay, coming into today, I have taken a
few days off from trading.
And so it helps me to get back into the
swing of things by visualizing
what I want to do, reminding myself how
my strategy works, and what I'm looking
for. You know, what is that repeatable
thing that I'm looking for every day
versus just kind of showing up and being
like, "Okay, I'm just going to trade."
Um and so for me um one of those big
things is
going into
um
some of my recordings of just
past trades that have done well that are
basically just our our wins that hit my
criteria.
And seeing that, you know, it's like,
"Hey, I want to just see the market come
up to a spot."
Um and
hit kind of make a double top, hit my
timing window, and then take a trade
based off of that. And so for me that
helps me, you know, kind of trigger,
"Okay, I'm not looking to just do random
things or react to the market. I want to
wait for a specific thing, you know, a
nice spike 8:00 or 30 minutes after the
market open to show up, and then, you
know, take a a reversal. And that's kind
of my bread and butter. And essentially
that's what my repeatable setup is. And
so going into today, looking for
something like that. If we look at the
ES
futures,
just to bring up my drawing tool here.
Um
on a 15-minute chart, you know, we had a
crazy sell-off um Friday.
And this was just Trump announced some
kind of tariff news on China. I think he
tweeted it or something, but the market
just went crazy over it.
Like looking at a daily chart,
um you know, it was a it was a huge
spike down.
Um and so
you know, we came to actually these
previous highs, which I think is a great
spot for a bottom.
Um and if if he doesn't really follow
through, you know, the thought is is it
just going to be, you know, a smaller
version of April where we just ripped
lower. And then once people were like,
"Oh, he's kind of backed off on that."
Um we might just shoot back up. And cuz
the market overall is insanely strong
right now.
And so I think it's totally possible
that today, looking at this, we probably
want to retest this to some extent, and
we have done that. Um you know, we
started to recover, pull back. This
really kind of tested this the gap we
had. There's still technically it closed
here and opened here, so there's a
pretty big gap there.
But we have come down to to really fill
this gap. This is the major gap here.
Haven't quite filled it. So I could see
a selling off a bit more to do that.
Same thing with the Nasdaq, pretty much
exactly the same setup. Um is we've had
this downtrend where trailing off
um
started to fill this gap, at least
tested the middle of it.
And so going into a smaller chart, what
that looks like for a trade today, well,
you know, 8:00 is here. Sometimes you
can get a reversal 15 minutes after the
open, but today I think if we can get a
good bottom, I think it's totally
reasonable. Actually going back to a
15-minute chart here is if we
target these overnight highs.
Um you know, the market kind of just
giving back this move up, finding some
strength.
Uh but just got to pick the right time
to buy the bottom for that. And so
um market hasn't opened yet. Got 7:30 my
time is when it opens. And then other
couple windows they like, 7:45 and 8:00.
These are my two spots where I want to
see it come down and reverse. If it's,
you know, either way at those timings,
um
that's kind of
lines up with what is repeatable for me
versus I find, you know, going into the
market and
just trying to enter in randomly just
does not work very well.
Um or or reacting and just reading and
thinking I can read the market in real
time um if it doesn't fit one of those
kind of things. So
um another thing would potentially be,
well, if it comes down, um bounces, and
then sits here for a minute and looks
like it's going to go long, maybe like a
fake lower and then goes long. That
could be another potential trade of a
fake out lower. Um to again try and fill
my bias to the long side.
So what I would like for a long here,
now that it's broken the lows,
um I would want a head and shoulders
to go long here. Cuz otherwise if
it's way more likely that we just
especially for the Nasdaq here is come
up here, test this, and just continue
lower.
Because we're not really bouncing off of
a a support level. Now we we could just
be doing a failed breakout of the
overnight lows here.
But big picture we could just be in a
downtrend
um that's going to continue lower, you
know? And so
I don't want to jump in long here
saying, "Hey, that's a nice failed break
lower."
Um when this downtrend is so strong.
I like this to the upside.
I really want to see I'm nervous that
I'm just going to
it's just going to pump me in and then
rip lower, but I think I'm just going to
get in long
um through that nervousness because
it it's made a nice head and shoulders
there. I'm going to just put my stop
down here.
Adjust this slightly.
Um and then target the highs.
It's a nice setup. Maybe I should have
my stop down here.
It's just hard when it's such a a rip.
Nasdaq has kind of done the same, head
and shoulders. I think it looks really
solid in terms of a setup. We had a nice
flush lower, nice little failed breakout
lower. In terms of target, I mean
initial is going to be here.
Um the previous open
or or the open of today, which is
basically here.
Uh if we rip up and hit 2x pretty fast,
I might jump out.
Um but I mean ideally we try and go for
the highs. But also one thing to keep in
mind
is pulling up a channel here.
As we could totally be in this kind of
channel right here.
It's not super defined.
You know, it's kind of off of these
three.
But that's pretty solid in terms of
resistance. So
so there's this downtrend line here from
that channel. And while we wait for this
trade, make sure to check out the
NinjaTrader Arena Cup $400,000 real
money prize pool tournament. Half the
spots are already taken. So make sure to
get your spot here in this QR code or
the link below.
I want to see how this reacts. I don't
want to do a trailing stop just yet
because you know, if it if it does like
a two-candlestick pullback here, just
like this, and then continues higher, I
want to I want to hold through that. I
don't want to get ripped out by that.
It's scary
at this size, and I'm still getting used
to that.
And it'd be really frustrating if it
does.
But pulling back you know, looking at
the Nasdaq here, trying to be unbiased
that I'm going to trade, pulling back to
here
and going higher is
totally reasonable.
Just kind of waiting to see what happens
at this point.
Okay, nice rip higher here.
Again, looking at this, um I'm just
going to take this out to clean up my
chart a bit.
Being aware that there's this downtrend
here, we could still totally just
reverse after that pop up.
And it could be like a final fake liar
higher.
Same thing on the Nasdaq.
I think if we bear break break my stop
here, it's basically breaking this
uptrend anyway.
I'm happy with how I'm managing it.
I just um emotionally I really would
love a
a win that's higher than
$1,700. If I get stopped out,
I'll be a little bummed about that. But
again, at at
at the end of the day, I
the entry was really good, which is what
I've been struggling with. Management,
you know, that just
plays out how it plays out. It's just
emotions talking, really.
Big picture again, this is such a good
for, you know, this whole swing, it's a
nice fake lower
and reversal higher. This is what I've
been looking for for weeks, really, with
a lot of these openings is reverse
or fake the way I don't want, and then
take a trade the direction that my bias
is or I think the big picture is.
I'm just going to move this down to 3x
at this point.
Uh
I I I think that's emotional.
I want to see what how this plays out.
I definitely if this starts popping up
here, I'm going to move trailing stop.
Like really tight here now.
Like up to 2x.
Nasdaq is popping as well.
For me mentally, I feel like getting 5K
on the trade is kind of a mental number
I really want right now.
Um
it's not good, but that's just the
reality.
But I also don't want to just let that
control what I'm doing.
I want to run a trailing stop here if
this is just going to continue to pop.
I don't think that's over greed.
I think that's
you know.
I'm just going to put a trailing stop
here right at the bottom of this candle.
Cuz I think either it's going to keep
going up or it's going to knock me out.
And if it knocks me out here at 4,700,
I'm totally happy with that.
Come on. Hold. Hold and keep going.
That's okay. I'm totally happy with
that.